by the way I have to be honest I haven't
played Fallout 4 played Fallout 3 I
thought that was a Legendary game I've
been uh
um can you make a case for Fallout 4
that I should or should I just wait till
Fallout five and when does that come I
think you should play Fallout 4. love to
hear your thoughts all right it's a
different game Skyrim is too I mean it's
uh we try to make them all different
they all they all they are fundamentally
different they all have their own tone
yeah so Fallout 3 and Fallout 4
intentionally a very different tone Oh
really interesting yeah so what what
what's that world like what's uh the
post-apocalyptic world of Fallout if you
can just briefly take a stroll into that
world tone wise well there's look in
entertainment there's a lot of
post-apocalyptic stuff and what what
makes Fallout tick is
the the world that was left behind the
world that blew itself up this utopian
world of nuclear energy and it all goes
wrong so I love the American dream of
that like how they visioned the future
in the 50s and that blowing itself up I
think that's like a super interesting
place to explore which is why we always
wanted to play in that World
um
and it does an amazing job of sort of
weaving
you know the drama and darkness of a
post-apocalyptic world with
B-movie humor
um you know it Winks at the camera
sometimes
often actually and
that when when you're in that world it
just has this this its own unique flow
and and Vibe outside of anything else
kind of in that genre
so Elder Scrolls has or at least Skyrim
has some humor
that's a little bit but Fallout leans
into it a little more a little bit more
a little bit more yeah yeah it does it's
like ironic humor it's the Duck and
Cover it's a get under your desk if the
bomb comes and everything will be fine
it's that type of humor so the funny
thing is I do think Fallout 3 is one of
the uh the greatest games ever uh you've
said that quote when we started Fallout
3 in 2004 we obviously had big ideas of
what we could do with it and I talked to
a lot of people from ex-developers to
press folks to fans what made it special
what are the key things you'd want out
in in a new one the opinions and I'll
put this mildly varied a lot but they
would all end the same like a
sternfather pausing for effect but do
not screw it up how do you not screw up
a game you have not screwed up many
games
yet
I mean back to the Fallout one yeah
yeah that was look that I remember that
we were met with a lot of skepticism in
terms of oh what are they gonna do with
this it was a beloved kind of isometric
turn-based role-playing game you know
awesome from when it came out
um and actually it was announced we had
finished Morrowind but not announced
Oblivion
but because we'd acquired the rights we
had to announce it because I think
interplay was a public company I don't
remember
um I just remember we had to announce it
and we're thinking there well you're
gonna we're gonna piss off all the Elder
Scrolls fans because we're announcing a
Fallout game we're probably gonna piss
off the hardcore Fallout fans because
we didn't make the original and clearly
we'll probably make a different kind of
game so I do remember you know there was
a lot of concern with with all of our
fans
um and fans of Fallout at the time and
so
I think it was pretty rewarding for us
that that game found the audience and
success that it that it did
um is one of my favorite projects that
I've ever ever worked on
and because it was so fresh for us and
we we had a very clear like even before
we had the rights like this is the game
we're gonna make like we're this is the
kind of thing we're gonna do and
we had done more when then we were
working on Oblivion
and it was kind of a breath of fresh air
to do it and what's kind of remarkable
is Fallout 3 comes out just you know two
and a half years after Oblivion and we
did all this DLC for Oblivion so we were
really really kind of prolific in how
our development how it was going so
um
I just remember enjoying making that
game so much because it was everything
we were doing was new
which which as did the world creation uh
was there some Innovation like
technically that was happening the world
creation like it was you know obviously
a different look even though some of us
a very few of us had worked in the
Terminator things
um the vat system the skill system and
we loved the original game so much so
you felt this responsibility
to bring it back in a big way and
reintroduce it in a way that you know as
much as we could scratch the same itch
when you when you played the original
game that had the same tone
are there some favorite things to you
about that world
that just kind of connected follow three
I love again I usually start with the
beginning I love the beginning I love
the character generation if you go if
you played it a lot or you're developing
it it starts to feel really long
but the first time you play it or second
I just think it's awesome
and this idea
it's a hard thing to say okay we want we
want you to feel like your character on
the screen even when you play like a
Skyrim you don't know what you were
doing before that but Fallout 3
you you were born in the vault and you
raised in the vault and you lived in the
vault but you experience a part of that
so it's a very different when you step
out it I think it really
and then the visuals are the visuals but
the emotional moment of stepping out of
the Vault you feel like you lived your
whole life in the ball
and you feel like you have a sense of
your past
right and I need to find my father
we should isn't it possible to have that
sense with like Elder Scrolls like a
life story like like childhood trauma
and stuff back to the human I mean you'd
have to like look you do some of that
stuff but they go through menus you know
pick your background we're doing that in
Starfield hey pick your background what
are you doing before this moment can you
pick your traumas and stuff like
that's a model yeah thank you for that
and then also make a mod for like a
therapist but a lot of it you know it's
in your head so you're gonna you're
gonna do that you're gonna pick this
background and do these things and
you're sort of like this is who I was
yeah and we intentionally Elder Scrolls
kind of make it a as much of a blank
slate you know I'll just goes a little
bit more of a blank slate game to who
you are which has a lot of positives and
and Fallout for us has been more of a
this is this this was your life before
here's who you were go be who you want
to be but this is the background it's a
little more strict